so i've just had my consultation with
the dietitian and uh he's put me on what
they call the paleo diet
or as i will refer to as the cavemen
that um i suppose some of the clusters
for me is that some of the things that i
love most like eggs and more
predominantly meat while still in there
and available to me in quantities that
will see me through um the choice of
fruits not that i'm a massive fruit
eater but the choice of fruits that are
left to me to eat i'll have to pay a
little more attention to and pick the
ones up that i could see myself eating
um so apart from that yeah it looks like
it should be challenging um it looks
like there's gonna be stuff in there
that i'm seriously gonna miss
uh but it's for a three week or four
week period just to see how the diet
adapts to myself and how i adapt to it
and it'll be interesting to see um i'll
get on with it uh but yeah i suppose if
the cavemen did it back in the day and
they didn't have any of the modern day
problems that we have today then it
should be good for us so we'll give it a
go see what happens and uh start all of
that first thing tomorrow morning